[Aplausos]
[Música]
cuando en febrero de 2022 docenas de
tanques helicópteros y soldados rusos
atravesaron la frontera ucraniana Los
dirigentes de la Unión Europea no solo
entendieron que los tambores de la
guerra estaban sonando en su propia
puerta sino también que su frágil
seguridad energética había desaparecido
sin embargo el tiempo ha pasado y aunque
la guerra en Ucrania y las sanciones a
Rusia continúan hoy las cosas se ven de
forma muy diferente la ue alcanzará su
objetivo de almacenamiento de gas meses
antes de la fecha límite suministro de
gas a la ue cuando Rusia entró en modo
de autodestrucción Europa se prepara
para la primera ola de frío a prueba de
sistemas energéticos queridos amigos
amigas del terror energético en Bruselas
ya queda muy poco sí Europa tiene hoy
una energía más cara y eso está
afectando a muchísimas industrias pero
pese a todo los peores pronósticos no se
han cumplido en verano incluso pudimos
ver declaraciones como esta el
almacenamiento de gas de la ue ha
alcanzado el 90 por mucho antes de lo
previsto esto nos ayudará a estar
seguros este invierno juntos estamos
dejando de depender del gas Ruso y
seguimos trabajando en paralelo para
diversificar el suministro energético en
el futuro claro que aún es pronto para
cantar
Victoria Si antes de la Guerra el gas
ruso representaba cerca del 40% del
total importado por la ue desde entonces
su peso ha disminuido a toda velocidad
ha sido mayormente sustituido por la
masiva importación de gas licuado
procedente de Estados Unidos y algunos
socios africanos algo que ha podido
mitigar la falta de gas este invierno
pero que podría no ser del todo
sostenible a largo
plazo Sí para el invierno de 2024 se ha
logrado garantizar un stock suficiente
de gas sin embargo los dolores de cabeza
podrían haberse tan solo pospuesto y es
que veréis en teoría la Unión Europea
podría aumentar las entradas de gas
natural licuado en el corto plazo en
unos 60,000 millones de metros cúbicos
respecto al promedio de 2021 El problema
es que todo el mundo está peleando por
este mismo gas y no solo hablamos de
Europa sino también de Asia hoy por hoy
el mercado de gas natural está
tremendamente ajustado cualquier
imprevisto que pueda producirse podría
disparar los
precios Así que Europa necesita nuevas
fuentes de energía y recursos naturales
y lógicamente para lograr nuevas Fuentes
pues hac falta nuevos socios La pregunta
es en quién se puede confiar en un mundo
Cada vez más revuelto en un Oriente
medio Al rojo vivo en un sudeste
asiático bajo el acecho de china en un
continente africano quizás donde Las
Guerras brotan por doquier no sé amigos
pero no parecen las mejores opciones del
planeta no al menos las más seguras no
os parece pero un momento y qué ocurre
con América Latina pues Venezuela
concreta un acuerdo con repsol y eni
para exportar gas a Europa la ue apura
el acuerdo con el mercosur y prometió
más inversión ies en litio en Argentina
chile y la Unión Europea refuerzan
vínculos en hidrógeno verde con miras
hacia un desarrollo sostenible Brasil
registró producción récord del petróleo
y gas en septiembre queridos amigos
latinoamérica no solo cuenta con
gigantescas reservas petroleras y
gasíferas además de otros muchísimos
recursos naturales sino que además es
una región donde los choques armados
siguen brillando por su ausencia y
precisamente por eso aquí en v al
politic nos hemos hecho unas cuantas
preguntas puede ser latam un socio
fiable para lograr la transición
energética que se ha propuesto llevar a
cabo Bruselas Qué países del cono Sur
pueden sostener una relación estratégica
con la Unión Europea sería capaz América
Latina de sustituir a la mismísima Rusia
Pues todo esto y más os lo contamos
gasolina y arranquemos
Pero antes Solo una pregunta te has
parado a pensar en lo que te estás
perdiendo por no usar el patrocinador
del vídeo de hoy Surf Shark lo primero
de todo y más importante es la seguridad
en la red con Surf Shark tu actividad
online está fuertemente protegida
cifrada y a salvo de ojos curios además
con clan web te despides de los anuncios
y el malware Y qué pasa con los emails
Pues que con Surf Shark alert te
enterarás al instante si alguien
intentado filtrar tu información ojo con
esto pero aún hay más surar es la
primera VPN comercial con servidores en
más de un centenar de países vamos algo
así como un pasaporte global a golpe de
click podrás acceder a cualquier
contenido bloqueado por ubicación Y si
te preocupa tener que elegir en Qué
dispositivo usarlo tranquilo porque con
la misma cuenta podrás proteger todos
tus dispositivos ya sea tu móvil tu
tablet la tele o el ordenador sin
límites Esto hace De hecho que puedas
compartir la cuenta con tus amigos así
entre todos cada uno pagaré apenas unos
pocos céntimos al mes además por ser
parte de la comunidad visual politic
este mes podrás disfrutar de la oferta
exclusiva de Black Friday se meses extra
totalmente gratis si usáis el código
politic os dejamos el link en la
descripción y dicho esto continuemos con
nuestro vídeo de
hoy una relación
tóxica
amigos amigas conocéis ese dicho que
dice guerra avisada no mata soldado pues
y La respuesta es que sí sois
Afortunados porque todo apunta que
Precisamente en Bruselas no lo habían
oído nunca y es que veréis poco a poco
la relación entre Europa y Rusia se fue
convirtiendo en algo así como una
relación tóxica una relación en la que
Europa se convirtió en una parte de la
relación tremendamente dependiente esto
quedó perfectamente claro cuando en 2014
Moscú y kief tuvieron su primera
enganchada tras la anexión rusa de
crimea Obama insta a la ue a
diversificar sus fuentes de energía para
acabar con la dependencia de Rusia la
dependencia europea del gas ruso podría
reducirse en un contexto de eficiencia
energética la vulnerabilidad de Europa
frente al gas ruso los estados miembros
europeos tienen diferentes grados de
exposición a la interrupción de los
suministros procedentes de Rusia que
deben abordarse para garantizar el
futuro de la unión energética de la ue
sin embargo en aquel momento Aunque la
desconfianza de Bruselas hacia el
kremlin existía Lo cierto es que no era
tan Grande Al fin y al cabo como
demonios iban los rusos a renunciar a la
tonelada de euros y dólares que cada año
les enviaban los países europeos una
representante Clara de este idea Por
ejemplo fue precisamente La cancillera
alemana Angela Merkel fijaos en la
perspectiva de la época era muy racional
y comprensible proveerse en gas de red
inclusive de Rusia que era menos Caro
que el gnl proveniente de otras regiones
del mundo en fin lo hecho pues hecho
está qué queréis que os
diga Europa solo se tomó en serio el
problema de la dependencia rusa cuando
el kremlin lanzó su zarpa sobre Ucrania
por segunda vez eso sí para ser justos
hay que decir que desde el año 2014
algunos equipos europeos estuvieron
trabajando en planes de contingencia en
torno a la importación masiva de gas
licuado algunas de esas iniciativas
prediseñadas de hecho dieron forma en
mayo del 2020 a la estrategia repower eu
hablamos Ni más ni menos que del plan
oficial de la Unión Europea para romper
con Rusia y reformular su matriz
energética por completo conforme a este
plan a partir de ahora se seguirán tres
criterios fundamentales en el viejo
continente ahorro energético sustitución
de fuentes de energía y diversificación
del origen de las energías fósiles Las
mayores inversiones En energía solar y
eólica junto a la ampliación del uso del
Carbón y la energía nuclear hicieron que
Durante los seis primeros meses del 2023
se registrara una importante caída en el
consumo de gas natural Así que el plan
parece estar funcionando el problema
amigos es que esto es algo que se ha
logrado con energía más cara y con un
enorme desafío logístico que podría
fallar en cualquier momento y justo Aquí
es donde de repente latinoamérica se ha
colocado en el punto de mira de Bruselas
desde el oro negro con burbujas de la
Venezuela Saudita hasta el gas de vaca
muerta en la Argentina o el sorprendente
caudal de reservas petroleras que ha
descubierto Brasil pero ahora bien
realmente latan puede acudir en auxilio
de Europa pues queridos amigos amigas
ahora mismo lo vamos a
[Música]
ver petróleo un tren
perdido no os engañamos y os decimos que
Rusia no es un proveedor nada pero que
nada fácil de constituir sin embargo las
reservas de crudo de Rusia se calculan
en unos 107,000 millones de barriles de
crudo frente a más de 320,000 millones
que sumarían México Argentina Colombia
Brasil y Venezuela sin embargo pese a
tener más petróleo el rendimiento del
nuevo mundo es cuanto menos
decepcionante como podéis ver solo
Brasil Ha logrado incrementar con fuerza
su producción en los últimos años
Mientras tanto Venezuela y México que
entraron en el siglo XXI como Auténticos
Titanes del petróleo han ido de mal en
peor al tiempo que la producción
Argentina y colombiana ha permanecido
estancada para que os hagáis una idea
según estimaciones del Energy institute
estas cinco naciones producían en 2003
cerca de 9,6 millones de barriles
diarios dos décadas después la suma
apenas llega a 7 millones y no es porque
no tengan crudo sino esencialmente
porque los diferentes gobiernos no han
sido capaces de explotarlo lo más
curioso de todo es que hace no tanto
tiempo la producción petrolera de
América Latina era mucho mayor que la de
Rusia en Venezuela qué os voy a contar
la revolución bolivariana acabó de raíz
con el sueño petrolero y no lo hizo por
convicción sino básicamente por
incompetencia en México pasó algo muy
parecido la gestión de Pemex ha sido un
desastre y en Colombia Bueno aquí en
visual politic ya os contamos como petr
quiere acabar de cuajo con esta
industria de todo solo Brasil parece
haberse tomado esta cuestión En serio y
eso que su producción se realiza sobre
todo en aguas super profundas lo que
lógicamente es mucho más complicado y
por potencialmente más caro el petróleo
presal brasileño gana una popularidad
mundial sin precedentes petrobras
destinará 41,000 millones de dólares de
inversión para aumentar la producción de
petróleo en un 19 por de aquí a 2027 y
eso no es
[Música]
todo ya no es que América Latina tenga
problemas para extraer su petróleo Es
que tampoco han logrado desarrollar una
capacidad razonable de refino que es el
proceso que hace falta para lograr que
el oro negro con burbuja se convierta en
combustible salvo Brasil la capacidad
del resto de la región permanece anclada
En los niveles de los 80 de locos todo
esto amigos es lo que explica que pese a
tener muchos recursos no sea raro Ver
noticias como estas la alarma por la
escasez de combustible se extiende a
Ciudad de México la escasez de gasolina
en Venezuela una crisis convertida en
rutina la escasez de nafta se hace
sentir en el comienzo del fin de semana
largo El problema es que la capacidad de
refino deuropa ha seguido un camino Muy
pero que muy similar a nadie le gusta
tener sucias y feas refinerías cerca de
casa en otras palabras que toda esta
falta de inversión hace que a corto
plazo la capacidad de América Latina
para sustituir a Rusia como proveedor
predilecto de Europa sea limitada Pero
si por ahora El crudo latinoamericano no
parece la opción definitiva qué ocurre
con el gas pues
[Música]
atentos la solución del gas
latino vale No es un secreto que si
hablamos de gas Rusia es todo un campeón
mundial un Coloso con más de 40 billones
de metros cúbicos de reservas probadas
el gas de Rusia es cinco veces más
grande que el gas conocido de América
Latina sin embargo aquí la industria
latina se ha comportado mucho mejor que
la petrolera y además el frakin podría
llegar a obrar Milagros eso sí tenemos
que volver a mirar caso por caso por
ejemplo en Brasil el gas natural tiene
un uso Industrial muy importante sin
embargo siguen tirando gas Sí sí me
habéis oído bien tirando gas quemándolo
y necesariamente por falta sobre todo de
infraestructuras luego por otro lado
México es uno de los países mejor
situados su sector gasífero está
altamente desarrollado pero tiene una
característica dominante su
interdependencia con Estados Unidos
México exporta gas natural a Estados
Unidos pero también lo importa Para
aprovechar los bajos costes de
procesamiento de su vecino
norteamericano esto ha impulsado la
construcción y finalización de enormes
redes de gasoductos en todo el país red
de gasoductos guagalajara ya operan su
totalidad Pacific limited invertirá
14,000 millones de dólares en un
gasoducto en México Estados Unidos
cerrará 2023 con exportaciones récord de
gas natural gracias a México en cuanto a
la Argentina entre 2005 y 2015 el país
gaucho se quedó atrás por culpa del
agotamiento de Los Pozos convencionales
los argentinos llegaron incluso a tener
que importar gas pese a contar con vaca
muerta una de las reservas de gas
potencialmente más grandes de todo el
planeta por fortuna ahora eso está
cambiando y de hecho en julio de 2023 se
inauguró el gasoducto presidente Néstor
kisner que le permitirá desde 2024
volver a exportar gas en Bolivia sin
embargo no parecen de enorabuena el
gobierno boliviano admitió que se acabó
el gas para 2029 el país deberá
importarlo el presidente Luis Arce dijo
que las reservas se han agotado y que
las exportaciones Argentina y Brasil
deben interrumpirse lo que deja un
enorme hueco en la economía del país
finalmente amigos Venezuela es el único
país que ha registrado los últimos años
una importante caída en sus niveles de
[Música]
producción de todas formas al igual que
ocurre con el petróleo las buenas
intenciones no bastan tener reservas o
incluso niveles de producción relevantes
no basta hace falta falta también tener
la infraestructura necesaria para poder
exportar el gas Pues bien aquí los
latinos también van muy pero que muy por
detrás de los rusos por supuesto No solo
hace falta gasoductos para poder
exportar el gas hasta Europa hacen falta
también plantas de licuefacción esto es
instalaciones que permitan convertir el
gas el líquido para así poder
transportarlo en grandes barcos
metaneros en otras palabras que
latinoamérica necesitará de muchas
inversiones y varios años para hacer
todo esto posible eso sí a la larga
podrían encajar con las necesidades
europeas sin embargo estamos todavía muy
lejos de que que eso sea algo relevante
a corto plazo ni el gas mexicano ni los
hidrocarburos de vaca muerta ni los de
alta mar de Brasil podrán sustituir a
Rusia en el mix energético de Europa
Pero entonces La pregunta es en qué
solución están pensando en Bruselas sin
socios posibles qué podemos esperar a
partir de 2025 para la matriz energética
del viejo continente es que acaso la
seguridad energética europea se fue para
no volver pues
[Música]
atentos hidrógeno la respuesta está
dentro de
Europa queridos amigos de visual politic
ya sé lo que muchos estaréis pensando
Seguro seguro que en Bruselas cuentan
con que las renovables sean la solución
a todo verdad Y es que a ver si pensáis
así no podemos culpar en las últimas
décadas el optimismo sobre la energía
solar y la energía eólica ha sido enorme
y lo cierto Es que hoy su rol es clave
la capacidad de las renovables europeas
ha incrementado un 100% en los últimos
20 años desde luego ha sido un proceso
clave para que Europa no se quedara
oscuras tras el apagón de los gasoductos
rusos sin embargo pese a ello la
esperanza de Bruselas parece estar en un
combustible pero no en uno fósil estamos
hablando por supuesto de
hidrógeno la generación de energía a
base de hidrógeno es posible cuando en
una pila de combustible el hidrógeno se
introduce por un lado y el oxígeno por
el otro en el lado del hidrógeno los
protones se separan y crean una
corriente eléctrica los electrones
liberados generan electricidad y en el
lado del oxígeno se combinan con los
protones y forman agua como único
subproducto
y no tranquilos no es que nos queramos
poner técnicos lo que ocurre es que
necesitamos entender Cómo se produce
electricidad con el hidrógeno para
entender una realidad clave su
deslocalización Y es que veréis el
proceso no está sujeto a ninguna reserva
yacimiento o insumo que esté atado a una
realidad geográfica y de hecho Ahí
radica su enorme potencial el hidrógeno
podría llegar a garantizarle a Europa la
autosuficiencia
[Música]
energética como Es lógico lo único que
sí hace falta en este proceso es el
hidrógeno pero este puede obtenerse de
diferentes formas por ejemplo se conoce
como hidrógeno gris aquel producido
mediante fuentes de energía de origen
fósil como gas natural el petróleo o el
carbón mientras el hidrógeno verde es el
producido a partir de fuentes de energía
renovables y con bajas o nulas emisiones
contaminantes asociadas al
[Música]
proceso pero Qué diferencia el hidrógeno
exactamente de la energía eólica o solar
Pues básicamente qu es alm almacenable
el hidrógeno amigo se puede almacenar y
Por tanto se puede utilizar cuando sea
necesario por ejemplo como combustible
para generar electricidad para muchos
esto resolvería el gran problema que
tienen las energías renovables
convencionales la intermitencia y la
irregularidad incluso Europa podría
llegar a exportar este combustible
limpio Claro que esta opción también
despierta muchas dudas sobre suficiencia
muchos expertos argumentan que nunca
será un proceso eficiente Y que además
hace falta una infraestructura adecuada
que llevaría mucho tiempo y dinero
construir pero sea como sea Lo cierto es
que el hidrógeno está en los planes de
Bruselas y ya hay muchas inversiones
contempladas para desarrollar esa fuente
de energía afortunadamente la
infraestructura de gas natural existente
puede actuar como catalizador para
ampliar el transporte de hidrógeno a
corto y medio plazo la mezcla de
hidrógeno con gas natural puede
facilitar el desarrollo inicial del
comercio mientras que la reutilización
de gasoductos puede reducir
significativamente el coste de
establecer redes nacionales y regionales
de hidrógeno sin ir más lejos en
septiembre del 2022 un montón de países
europeos Austria Bélgica Dinamarca
Finlandia Francia Grecia Italia Países
Bajos Polonia Portugal Eslovaquia España
y Suecia suscribieron este proyecto que
contempla hasta 5200 millones de euros
en financiación pública y 7000 millones
de euros adicionales en inversiones
privadas por otro lado en marzo de 2023
la Unión Europea anunció la creación del
banco europeo del hidrógeno el cual se
encargará de mitigar la diferencia de
costes entre el hidrógeno renovable y
los combustibles fósiles para los
primeros proyectos operativos del
continente el resultado Pues que como
podéis ver en este mapa Europa es la
región con más proyecto de hidrógeno de
todo el mundo queridos amigos y amigas
hoy es imposible saber si finalmente
será el hidrógeno el gas natural licuado
o incluso los suministros de América
Latina los que den forma a la nueva
matriz energética de Europa las
oportunidades y los problemas están
sobre la mesa lo único seguro es que
Europa nunca más será dependiente del
gas y el petróleo ruso América Latina
vuelve a tener así una gran oportunidad
para encontrar una enorme fuente de
inversiones y de dólares La pregunta es
la aprovechará Pues solo el tiempo podrá
respondernos pero ahora la pregunta es
para ti Qué papel crees que jugará el
hidrógeno en la seguridad energética de
Europa podrá América Latina aprovechar
esta oportunidad para lograr un enorme
río de dólares y euros déjanos Como
siempre tu respuesta en los comentarios
y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like y
suscribiros a este canal si es que aún
no lo habéis hecho Ah importante
recordad que con el código politic
acabado en K este mes podréis disfrutar
de seis meses extra totalmente gratis
con su Shark el link como siempre en la
descripción una vez más Muchas gracias
por estar ahí un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]
than